I got an exclusive sneak peek with the
star panelists it's bigger it's better
no idea how's this for an exclusive
I got a behind-the-scenes tour of the
show's crazy costume you know this is a
gender-neutral leopard you won't know
what sex this character is for probably
a few weeks I'm not gonna give you any
any hints but I think I figured this one
out
thanks for nothing Robin over here let's
scoot over to what I now consider my
spirit animal I think this is actually a
good representative of the celebrity
that's behind ya take a guess as to who
you think it might be based off of all
the celebrities well it could be Willie
Nelson in there no that's no that's not
a bad yes for season two we are getting
more mast singers up to sixteen instead
of twelve and yeah last season we got
Joey Fatone Tori Spelling and Donny
Osmond this season I'm told the star
power goes up a notch how can you even
keep it a secret at this place it's even
more on lockdown it's hilarious even
when I Drive in to the lot I see people
with capes and hoodies and masks like
random masks so I'm like where'd you
pick that one oh they'll let some names
leak out there that those of you so
they'll be like Oh her Brad Pitt's on
this season the security on set is super
tight there's confidentiality agreements
and even the panelists go incognito I
have to wear a dr. ken mask every time I
come to set I go around wearing a Robin
Thicke mask whatever you can tell I'm
doing a Robin Thicke impression I have a
Robin Thicke mask and a full-length
mirror wherever I go we were the same
jokes we're so close
you
[Music]